well with the returned Jafar doing so
well in sales and the animated series
being a pretty modest hit it only made
sense to wrap it all up with one more
Aladdin movie Aladdin and the King of
Thieves
a much better sequel than the last one
not only is it more cinematic in both
the story and its visual style but it
actually puts the focus back on Aladdin
and the troubles he's going through
doesn't make it good I don't know if I
can go that far there are still a lot of
things that don't work about it but I
can at least say I was genuinely
entertained and even kind of impressed
aladdin and Jasmine are finally getting
married yeah I guess they pushed that
whole three days thing off of it
but like he said he's the Sultan and can
change the laws so why even have a law
that she has to be married oh who knows
fairy tales haha but Aladdin is feeling
sad because he can't invite his father
to the wedding because well he never
knew his father but that all changes
Wade discovers his father is actually
the king of the forty fee then tries to
rob the wedding he's trying to get this
scepter that's in the palace that
contains an Oracle that can tell him
where the greatest treasure of all is
the hand of Midas hoddan and his father
played by John rhys-davies finally meet
up and don't know what to really make of
each other the father is confused about
how we made it to a place of royalty and
Aladdin is confused why his father is
still a thief both want a relationship
to bloom but both have issues trusting
the other especially Aladdin trusting
his father and we find out that
rightfully so
the father still wants to find the hand
of Midas and will do anything to achieve
it so Aladdin puts off his wedding and
goes back and forth trying to figure out
whether or not he wants to help his
father and get the treasure or if he
just wants his father back to be well
his father and yeah this is kind of the
main problem with the film I give them
credit for tackling the issue of
father's that aren't very good fathers
as it can be a very tough issue
sometimes can turn over a new leaf but
other times are still caught in this
selfish cycle but here's the problem
Aladdin's father cycle doesn't really
make sense
he says they left Aladdin because he
couldn't provide for him and his wife so
he goes and joins the 40 thieves to get
his treasure so that well he can support
them they clearly find a lot treasures
but he never comes back well okay maybe
they are building him up is kind of a
deadbeat dad but no they tried to give
him these
sympathetic moments which I'm usually
for except it doesn't match at all what
he was talking about anyone that talks
like how this father talks about his son
wouldn't do the things that he does he
would be happy to go to the wedding he
wouldn't give a crap about the treasure
in fact there's really no point to care
about the treasure he can just go and
live in the palace it's all just a pride
thing but then at the end he throws away
the treasure even though he tried so
hard to get it but wait Aladdin was
helping him find the treasure - why does
Aladdin suddenly care about this it's so
weird to see a lad and just abandon his
wedding and then be like hey let's go
find this treasure that really I don't
care about but he doesn't really
cheerfully and the father is all okay
with it and it just doesn't add up
the motivations constantly go back and
forth but not in a way I feel was
intentional if you want to see this kind
of story done so much better watch
Adventure Time and Finn's connection to
his father or even strangely enough
Fresh Prince of bel-air and his
connection with his real father these
shows get it and they know how to
explain it well I don't think this one
really does it feels more like they want
to do something with Aladdin connecting
to his father but they also want a
treasure hunt so they just kind of smash
them together and yeah given the
probable short amount of time that they
had on this I guess I can't be surprised
what we got but that still doesn't mean
that the heart and focus works and when
the heart and focus doesn't work the
film really suffers and it's hard to get
behind it but that's not the only
problem
the first Aladdin was very good at
balancing out the characters everybody
felt like they got the appropriate
amount of screen time in this one it's
mostly on Aladdin which is better than
return to Faro's mostly on Iago but all
Jasmine does is show some support and
then mostly stays out of the picture and
all the genie does is want to plan a
wedding speaking of which let's talk
about the genie because Robin Williams
is back to voice him and that's both
kind of a pro and a con it's a pro
because it's Robin Williams as
improvising is incredible but it's a con
because unlike the first film they don't
always know when to cut him off grant it
in the original they do leave the camera
on in too long sometimes but they knew
to keep the focus on Aladdin and the
story and so forth in this one I
actually kind of dreaded whenever the
genie was gonna come on screen even
he made me laugh it just didn't connect
to anything it's like he comes in and
just hijacks the movie when we could be
spending more time trying to get the
motivations of Aladdin and his father
down or give Jasmine more time or make
the villain more interesting just every
time he shows up even when it's
hilarious
it still feels out of place at first I
thought the songs were gonna be really
good the first one really had me tapping
my feet and kind of humming it
afterwards but then outside of a do way
from Aladdin and jasmine
they all sound exactly like that I swear
it's like the exact same song in the
exact same rhythm just a few notes are
missing or changed there's very little
variety which is ironic because I know
more than one songwriter worked on this
but for all its problems like I said
there are a lot of good things Wayans
jokes though they do go on too long are
still mostly funny they do at least try
to tie in some of the characters at the
end Jasmine throws a punch and the genie
gets a few action scenes and like I said
you can tell they're trying to go that
extra mile look at some of this
animation this is the same crew that
brought the Aladdin TV show to life TV
shows back then didn't have a big
animation budget so for them to come
together and pull off something that
looks this good it's really impressive
the angles the movement the lighting the
colors you can tell they knew this was
going to be the last thing Aladdin
related and they want to try their
hardest to make it good and give them
credit for all the action and singing
there are a lot of times where people
just sit down and talk when it's
actually needed and welcomed and those
scenes don't feel forced they flow very
naturally it's just once again the
motivations there's a difference between
being intentionally complex and sloppily
complex
I feel like this movie had a lot of
really good scenes and ideas but no
concentrated narrative to have them
connect or flow so it's a tough call I
don't see it really working as a film
but I'm also kind of happy I saw it it
was visually interesting it was creative
you could tell it was trying to have a
real heart and soul and I give a credit
that was trying to wrap up both the TV
series and the movies it even ends with
the merchant singing the song at the end
those are kind of nice bookends I get a
feeling if I was a little kid I'd be
into it and as an adult there's some
neat stuff it's just that now that ever
really
but you gotta give prop to the directors
and animators who you know we're on a
tough deadline for this for Disney
sequels and show they're almost never
given enough time to be fleshed out this
was a valiant attempt to justly wrap up
another Arabian night